it's a new week and that means new
releases and this week we're opening the
toy box taking out our childhood heroes
and making them fight to the death it's
toy soldiers war chest eighth Army's and
one toy box to defend the toy soldiers
war chest Hall of Fame addition is a
fast-paced mix of strategy defense and
action gameplay that brings to life
childhood favorites like GI Joe star
bright and most importantly he man you
can get it on current-gen consoles and
PC and the toys come alive starting on
the 11th also this week we get bedlam a
first person shooter based on a novel of
the same name by award-winning British
author Christopher brookmire in bedlam
players take on the role of heather
quinn AKA athena programmer at medical
scanning developer nero sphere who finds
herself transported into the world of
starfire a 90s FPS she remembers from
her teen years searching for an
explanation and way home she ventures
beyond Starfire to discover a vast realm
of interconnected game worlds
documenting the evolution of the SPF
genre and video games in general the
game looks weird as hell and I want to
try it out if you're intrigued to you
can check it out on the 13th the creepy
eerie foreboding yet super good-looking
everybody's gone to the rapture is set
to release this week this is created by
developer the Chinese room who you might
remember scaring the crap out of you
with their other game amnesia so you
know this first-person adventure game is
gonna creep you out it's set after the
apocalypse supposedly but instead of
what you would think of an apocalypse
you know Q burnt buildings and destroyed
structures everything in here looks
really good so I think that's a bad
thing I don't really know what's going
on I just know it's super creepy and I
want to play it it's coming out on the
11th
going to quickly burn through a few
games that have come out on new
platforms that I think you guys should
know about goat simulator comes to ps3
and ps4 this week brothers a tale of two
sons makes its way to current gen
platforms one of my favorite games makes
its way to ps4 this week it's gauntlet
player edition and fallout shelter makes
its debut on Android for the rest of us
so you can start making babies without
an iphone and just one more game before
you go I gotta tell you about centuries
which is coming out of early access this
week it's a little difficult to describe
but it's basically a musical performance
puzzle game where you put soundblox into
a spinning loop to solve puzzles and
while you're doing that you're creating
original music that's just really serene
and enjoyable to listen to and I
definitely recommend it find your inner
musician on the 12th for further details
visit gamespot com release dates are
based on retailer listings and are
subject to change see you next week